What I love most about being up here is
simply being immersed in nature every
day, and being able to share that with
the students. The Biological Station is
unique in that it gives students an
opportunity not to just merely learn things.
Up here, I can showcase and demonstrate
the natural world biological phenomena,
and give students a real experience in
field biology. The primary course that I
teach every summer is General Ecology,
which is an introductory lecture-based
course with his little lecture as
possible. We'll have a three-hour lecture
and then we'll go out into the field and
do a variety of lab activities--anything
from setting nets-trap nets out on the
lake to Blue Gill studies. We've gone
rafting down rivers. You read about a lot
of things in a biology textbook, but to
actually be out in the field and doing
these things-the research element is so
much more real. One of the big advantages
to Hillsdale College, throughout its
curriculum, is that we have a lot of the
opportunities, toys and things that big
schools have, and unlike a lot of big
schools, our students actually get to use
them. For research, students get their own
project. I'm looking at the population
density of the redback salamanders. I
chose to do research here because I
enjoy being outside and working with
live animals instead of in a lab. We're
basically catching a whole bunch of them
and microchipping them and collecting data.
because nobody's really studied these salamanders before.
It's kind of a new project for Hillsdale College.
I've had students invent new
field equipment, new field techniques. It's a very
real opportunity for students to go out
and see what ecologists do, not merely learn about it in a classroom.